well Kristen Bell and Dax Shepard also
have something to celebrate five years
of wedded bliss and luckily for us they
have shared many of their most
uncensored moments with et fun as it
turns out we've been married for five
years congratulations it's our
anniversary it's not happy anniversary
to you these two have happy memories of
their quickie courthouse wedding but
what they don't remember is the actual
date they said I do we generally find
out it's our anniversary by one of our
mothers texting us like happy
anniversary and then we both panic and
like I gotta go get some flowers not
remembering our anniversary comes from a
very specific commitment to celebrate
our marriage every day we'd really try
to go like hey every day even when
you're being so annoying I'm still so
happy and excited to be married to so
here's why this Hollywood marriage works
first they have a blast together from
roller rink birthday parties to African
safaris
[Music]
neck's they share each other's
obsessions like their Game of Thrones
love that turned into an epic music
video this is a stupid video we wanted
to make forever and we finally did it
and really these two are up for anything
like when Dax directed Kristen in chips
do you were talking with Josh Duhamel in
that scene and I said Chuck Norris kiss
him and I had been wanting to Chuck
Norris kiss Duhamel for a while and by
the way thanks for being my wingman
absolutely but the real reason they're
total relationship goals their devoted
parents who admit they work hard to keep
their marriage healthy our relationship
wasn't perfect from the moment we met we
had a couple years of hating each other
and then loving each other and and then
going to couples therapy and we like
worked it out you know what we earned
each other oh I love that here's another
fact about Cristen index
she couldn't actually remember if they
had a prenup or not so she texted Jax to
ask him turns out they don't have one
[Music]